c'est avec michel cohen directeur de
recherche émérite au cnrs spécialiste du
mozambique
bonsoir et merci d'être avec nous ce
soir sur arte france
est-ce qu'on peut recontextualiser avec
vous pour commencer pour comprendre ce
qui se joue aujourd'hui au mozambique
d'abord sur la situation géographique de
la ville de palma où a eu lieu l'attaqué
jihadistes oui alors la ville de palma
est une ville c'est une bourgade située
à l'extrême nord-est du mozambique qui
est à vous avez dit 10 km mais je dirais
même 7 km2 afrology qui est le l'endroit
où l'entreprise total pétrolières à ses
installations et où doit être monté une
usine de liquéfaction du gaz
donc c'est également une ville de très
près de la frontière avec la tanzanie ce
qui peut permettre des passages entre
les deux pays
et c'est historiquement la zone soit idy
du mozambique donc une zone très lié à
tout ce qui se passe dans l océan indien
mais ce n'est pas la première fois que
les djihadistes attaques des bourgades
puisque bosingwa dabaya avait déjà été
attaquée est prise il y à déjà de cela
plus d'une année les autorités à du
mozambique sont confrontés violon violon
temps du rec insurrection aussi depuis
2010 est c'est ça c'est à dire que tout
à fait aux débats au départ c'était un
mouvement c'était une dissidence salafis
c'était un mouvement religieux mais qui
petit à petit s'est militarisée et les
premières les premières actions armées
ont commencé en 2017 et au début on
pensait que ça ne durerait pas beaucoup
que ce n'était qu'un petit groupe
en fait le mouvement n'a cessé de se
renforcer parce qu'il faut bien voir que
la situation au cap baudelle gadoue donc
cette province du nord ouest du
mozambique est extrêmement compliqué
socialement très très difficile il ya
énormément de facteurs qui se mélangent
depuis le trafic de drogue depuis le
la chasse pour l'ivoire interdite
les rivalités entre réseaux de drogue
comme j'ai dit tout à l'heure et
également 7,7 dissidence religieuse ya
également des des rivalités ethniques
mais les rivalités années que n'arrive
jamais seul ils essaient produit aussi
que depuis l'indépendance du mozambique
en 1975 c'est un groupe ethnique encore
plus au nord à la frontière du
mozambique avec frontières de la
tanzanie qui a comment dire qu'il ya eu
l'essentiel des ressources économiques
parce que il avait été le fer de lance
de la libération et qu'ils étaient donc
très bien implanté dans le front de
libération du mozambique le parti qui a
vaincu le colonialisme portugais et qui
est au pouvoir aujourd'hui depuis 1975
et donc comme cette lame les richesses
ont été accaparées principalement par ce
groupe ethnique cela crée des
ressentiments ethniques mais ça serait
complètement faux de dire que la guerre
civile dans le nord du mozambique est un
conflit inter tribal ou interethniques
il ya énormément de facteurs qui se
mélange entre eux pour faire une
situation complètement pourri mais c'est
une vraie guerre civile aujourd'hui
c'est pas simplement un petit groupe
terroriste qui mène des actions armées
et alors qui soutient ce groupe
terroriste les assaillants qui ont pris
la ville de palma l'attaquent et une
attaque d'ampleur visiblement
minutieusement préparé les forces
gouvernementales
d'ailleurs est ce qu'elles sont en
déroute ou alors est-ce qu'elle prépare
une contre attaque
écoutez on a très très peu
d'informations l'armée mozambicaine
n'est pas du tout championne de la
communication la plupart des
journalistes sont interdits d'aller sur
le terrain et donc je ne saurais je
préfère ne rien dire parce que je risque
de dire des bêtises ya probablement un
groupe de 100 à 150 djihadistes qui ont
attaqué la ville depuis mercredi ils ont
pris l'armé par surprise parce que
l'armée les attendait par le sud parce
que vers le sud ils ont des bases
importantes et les djihadistes alors
qu'ils sont arrivés pas par par le nord
et même les mercenaires étrangers n'ont
pas pu réussir à repousser les
djihadistes alors c'est pas énorme 100 à
mais visiblement
ils ont aussi des soutiens dans la ville
il faut se rappeler que lorsqu'il avait
attaqué la ville de bosingwa d'appareils
à l'année dernière
les jihadistes avait été applaudi par
une partie de la situation c'est
pourquoi d'ailleurs personnellement
j'hésite beaucoup disent on dit toujours
les terroristes sont attaqués mais moi
en tant qu'historien je préfère appeler
cela une insurrection aux djihadistes
qui au départ est principalement due à
des facteurs locaux et qui seulement
ensuite à demander son affiliation à
l'état islamique donc aujourd'hui on
fait partie mais de là à dire que ça
serait simplement une déstabilisation
venus de l'étranger serait tout à fait
faux c'est une vraie guerre si d'une
régionale la ville de palma a été prise
le jour même où total annoncé la reprise
des travaux du site d'exploitation
gazière qui est censé être opérationnel
en 2024
est ce que vous y voyez un lien de cause
à effet alors c'est une excellente
question et je n'en ai pas la réponse
mais on peut essayer de réfléchir
des gens dit que cette rébellion s'était
simplement parce que il y avait
maintenant de nouvelles ressources dans
l'extrême nord du mozambique et c'était
pour empêcher le mozambique et le
gouvernement du mozambique d'en profiter
je pense que c'est une vision
extrêmement réductrice
comme je le disais tout à l'heure c'est
une insurrection locale qui a des
racines historiques locales il ya
beaucoup de facteurs qui se mélangent
qu'on a malheureusement pas le temps
en quelques instants de dévoiler de
déchiffrer mais maintenant que le groupe
est bien installé et que alors qu'on
annonçait son affaiblissement parce
qu'il y aurait la famine dans les bases
des insurgés etc
et c'est possible eh bien on voit que ce
groupe est encore capable de faire des
grandes
des grandes offensives il est possible
que tactiquement
alors que total vient d'annoncer la
reprise de ces travaux le groupe a dit
eh bien nous on va montrer qu'on est
bien vivant pour pour pour des raisons
tactiques
mais cette rébellion n'existe pas à mon
avis parce que total ou d'autres
compagnies étrangères vont exploiter le
gaz de l'extrême nord du mozambique
ce sont ce sont des choses concomitante
mais je crois qu'il serait très
réducteur d'en voir un rapport de cause
à effet merci beaucoup pour votre
éclairage michel quesne je rappelle que
vous êtes directeur de recherche au cnrs
et spécialiste donc du mozambique 1